[Music]  we all have a story to tell  but what makes each one different  [Music]  is not how the story ends  but rather the place where it begins  [Music]  holy god  mama says if we went across the water  they wouldn't understand the way we talk  if they can't understand you then  they're not listed  you know who you are would you  your buddy a belfast where everybody  knows you  hey  [Music]  we're looking to cleanse the community  away but you wouldn't want to be the old  man out in this street  touch my family and i'll kill you  so we gonna have to leave belfast we'll  fight this together  this is what this is war  open up  [Music]  are getting killed we can give these  boys a better job than we ever had  [Music]  oh  so  [Music]  you